did you know that the animatronics for
Five Nights at Freddy's took 15 months
to physically build and that the
creature designer for the movie had to
publicly announced that they didn't use
CGI for them well if you're anything
like me you are stoked for any and all
info about the upcoming release of the
movie stick around to hear a bunch of
behind the scenes action okay so it
probably won't come as much of a
surprise that Five Nights at Freddy's
fans are passionate and that means they
are absolutely here to support
everything F but it also means you have
to be careful about making any drastic
changes or big Swings with their beloved
IP the folks making the movie have found
this out in a big way a few times so far
the first was when the poster was
released and it featured the animatronic
characters with red eyes this wasn't
something that had been seen in the
games before and well people didn't love
that change people made their voices
heard and I think it's safe to assume
the movie team took that under
advisement it would be pretty surprising
if there were any red eyes that ended up
in the movie but hey you never know so
don't quote me on it speaking of anger
or at least annoyance about those
animatronic characters there were a few
posts online recently that dragged the
studio for using CGI the only thing is
they didn't actually use any to clear
things up creature designer Robert
Bennett had to officially announce that
they didn't he posted online pledging
that those effects were completely CGI
free hopefully that made people feel
better and finally the fans have been
pretty annoyed that the movie comes out
in theaters and on peacock on the same
day the thinking being the movie won't
earn nearly as much if people can just
watch it at home on a streamer in
response the folks from NBC Universal
put out a response saying it was planned
out this way on purpose they said it
meant people could enjoy it in a theater
on opening weekend or they could watch
it like 10 times in a row at home and
look for all the Easter eggs and I'm
sure it has nothing to do with trying to
get people to buy peacock subscription
sure sure sure sure sure there are
definitely some upsides to having the
animatronics in the movie be legit for
starters they were created by Jim
hensen's Creature Shop and if there's
one name that gives credibility in the
world of animatronics and puppets it's
Henson apparently a sizable chunk of the
$20 million movie budget went to
Henson's crew and I'm sure everyone is
happy about that cuz the creatures all
look incredible another cool aspect is
how involved and complex they are for
example it apparently takes six people
to operate the character foxy each
person is moving a separate part of her
body and they have to work in sync to
make things look realistic hella cool of
course having no CGI and all animatronic
creatures had some challenges too for
starters it took 15 months for the
Hensen Creature Shop to build them all
so that likely caused some delays on a
movie that was already seriously delayed
over the years more on that in a bit and
another downside is that the animatronic
characters had physical Motors in them
that would overheat after a while
according to the director Emma Tommy
shooting had to take regular breaks so
that the characters wouldn't overheat
and completely shut down speaking of
those characters you might be wondering
if the filmmakers had a favorite well at
one point a tweet came out that
basically pointed to Mr Cupcake as the
favorite among the crew in general but
that didn't apply to the top of the
movie making food chain apparently Emma
had a different character in mind at
least on the day she was asked about it
my favorite Five Nights at Freddy's
animatronic is chica but it changes
every day I love them all so much and
producer Jason Blum concurred my
favorite Five Nights at Freddy's
animatronic is also chica by now all of
us have seen the various official
trailers online so we've gotten our full
sneak peek of chica Mr Cupcake and the
rest but there was a time before that
when an unauthorized trailer was leaked
the internet went wild when grainy
footage of what we now know as the first
trailer was put online NBC Universal got
their best sleuth on it and it was
traced back to a user named Kaiju Cooper
he came clean admitting he had filmed it
off of his screen after he was part of
an online survey giving feedback about
the trailer he gave a public apology so
at least that's something and the online
community seemed to be split over
whether to watch it on the one hand it
was the first real footage of the movie
and people were champing at the bit to
see something on the other hand it was
filmed off a computer screen onto a
phone didn't look amazing and so forth
so a lot of fans resisted the Temptation
if it feels like you've been waiting for
like almost a decade for this thing to
come out well that's actually accurate
Warner Brothers first announced plans to
make a movie version of Five Nights at
Freddy's in 2015 but as often happens in
Hollywood there were delays there were
rewrites there were directors like Chris
Columbus who signed on and then off
again it got to a point where Jason Blum
was getting mocked online for it it was
his white whale but finally it got made
and Jason is definitely relieved my
favorite thing about the 5 Nights at
Freddy's movie which we worked on a very
very very long time is that it actually
exists you're going to get to see it and
he's likely even more relieved that the
movie is already profitable before it
even opens that might sound insane but
because of the streaming and
distribution deals Blum housee was able
to make for FNAF the movie is already in
the black that would make it likely for
there to be a sequel but again don't
quote me on that I definitely don't have
Jason blum's cell number okay so if
you're like me and you've basically been
waiting since 201 15 for this movie to
happen you're probably going to rush out
to the theaters when it gets released or
watch it 10 times on peacock to find the
Easter eggs or both either way you're
pumped have any thoughts about the
making of the movie and BTS action pop
them in the comment section
below